the United States of America there's
nothing nothing beyond our capacity if
we work together
so God bless you all and may God protect
our troops
Mr President thank you thank you Mr
President Mr President okay classified
classified material next to your
Corvette what were you thinking
let me uh we're going to get a chance to
speak on all this God willing soon but
as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvette's in a
lock garage okay so it's not like you're
sitting out in the street but anyway
yes as well as my Corvette
um but as I said earlier this week
people know I take classified documents
and classified materials seriously
I also said we're cooperating fully and
completely the Justice Department's
review
as part of that process my lawyers
reviewed other places where documents in
my uh of from my time as vice president
were stored and they finished the review
last night
they discovered a small number of
documents of classified markings and
storage areas and file cabinets in my
home in my in my my my personal Library
this was done in the case of the Biden
pen and that this was done in the case
of the Biden Penn Center the Department
of Justice was immediately as was done
the Department of Justice was
immediately notified
and the lawyers arranged for the
Department of Justice to take possession
of the document so you're going to see
we're going to see all this unfold I'm
confident
[Music]
thank you
sir
she's doing really well she uh
um she was under a long time
uh for five hours because what they were
doing is they take out would do the mows
meaning remove what they thought what
might be cancerous and they'd have to
then go back and test it and see what it
was but she's doing really well she's up
we had a we had breakfast this morning
she's uh she's recovering
um and she's gonna be sore for a while
because of the work they did on her eyes
and uh but you know that's where one of
these uh these were but she is a zero
the zero to one percent chance of every
return of any cancer and so thank God
she's doing really well thank you
my life